business owners i think we can all agree
that one of the most important things
that happens as we grow
is that we learn frameworks and that's
why
when you look back at what you used to
accomplish you know years ago it seems
like you could fix those problems so
easily because you have frameworks with
which you've learned to think
right and so uh it took me six years to
build my first
eight figure company six and a half to
build my first eight and a half figure
uh sorry multiple eight figure company
because
that was the the same company the next
company that i did that was multiplied
figures was
it took me a year to build and the one
after that took me six months and so
we've gotten faster and faster and
faster at doing this and now we've done
over 120 million in sales
across different industries and one of
the key frameworks that i've
developed or helps me think through
things is something to share with you
today
all right so there's kind of three
levels
employees or talent right and this
really applies to you
or your uh your team itself because at
the beginning it's you
right and so depending on where you're
at you may you may be at one of these
levels
or you may have to recognize it in
others and i'm going to say
in in three different ways so i have a
nice little nine
nine grid here the simplest way to think
about this is in the beginning
you have to learn what to do all right
this these are the skills right
and that's because which you are in the
beginning is an individual contributor
all right that means you actually have
to get things done in order for them to
you know happen right and so what you're
doing at this point is you're doing
right all of your time is spent doing
the things right
learning what to do etc
now the reason it's really important to
be able to recognize where you're at is
because then you'll be able to look
through this framework and immediately
see what you need to do next
to the same degree you may have gone
through this but not have recognized the
shifts
and you can look at an employee and say
i think they are in this bucket i think
they are in this bucket i think they
have the potential to get to this bucket
etc
many times people will stick at one
level
because of their own beliefs that they
have about themselves which is why
we you know laila and i believe that
identity is very fluid if you want to be
successful because you have to be able
to change
what you think about yourself in order
to become the thing that's going to to
de-bottleneck the business because
ultimately
it's costing every single human on earth
a billion dollars a year
not knowing how to create a billion
dollars a year in revenue right and
that's how i always think about this
it's like it is costing me so much money
my ignorance is costing me so much money
and so hopefully with this video
i'll break down some of the other things
that you won't be ignorant to so you can
recognize them in other people
so level one is understanding what to do
right which means you're an individual
contributor and what your time is spent
is doing
all right the second level here is is
understanding uh how all right so you
started to do it
right the what you figure this out but
then you have to figure out how you're
actually doing it
right and the reason for that is because
the next level
you become a manager all right and
that's making sure that other people can
do that thing and they're consistently
executing at a level
that works right and so here what you're
doing
is you're teaching right you're teaching
other people to do
the thing right and so at the beginning
you're doing
right as an individual contributor you
have to focus on what it is right the
next level you're doing
you're doing all the doing and you're
like you know what i feel like i
understand this better right
i didn't feel like i understand the
sequence of how this works right and
then you can
teach other people how to replicate that
skill
and at the very end i'll show you how to
apply this to departments in a second
all right so
stay tuned for that but this is level
one right as you're looking at yourself
or an employee
right level two is oh i think this
person could teach other people i think
they could manage them
and as a quick caveat here like not
every like managers don't necessarily
need to know how to do something better
than an individual contributor there's
always going to be niche expertise etc
but they should understand how it works
right and so this is just an important
like
just nuance to note there right the
third level
is what i look at is the who right
and i know this may sound odd it's like
what and then how then who but that is
kind of what it evolves to
over time all right the title here
is a leader all right and these are very
different than managers which is
something that i had to i had to realize
as i was scaling the business and you
know usually at this level this is where
you're at your
you know three-ish million dollar a year
level and this is what allows you to
you know crack crack open to the million
plus uh
per month level so 10 10 million pluses
you have to have leaders
that are engaged right the thing that
you're doing here
is you're systematizing all right and so
what i'm gonna
i'll say this a different way too
because i think it's worth noting is
building the machine that builds the
machine
all right and the reason that's
important
is because first you're doing it then
you're teaching it
and then you need something that can
teach it for you
that's kind of how this works right so
it's always it's it's um
it's not delegating it it's
systematizing so it's really i was
trying to be thoughtful about what word
i was going to use there because it's
like
is it delegating it is it is it is it
handing it off it's it's systematizing
it and there's a lot of different ways
you can system you know build a machine
that builds the machine
but if you think through this in terms
of your own frameworks
the way the reason that i like this is
that you can actually grade yourself in
terms of where you're at
you can grade yourself in terms of where
a team member is at
and you can even grade departments
right within your within your business
which depending on what your size is
your departments
might just be might be things that you
were doing right if there's if you're a
solopreneur for example
then like you wear all the hats your
finance your hr your legal your i.t
your marketing your sales your product
your fulfillment your all of those
things right
but as you grow you know in the
beginning you'll have your first core
team of probably five people and they'll
fulfill each one of those functions you
have somebody who helps you with you
know delivery you'll have somebody who
helps you with
you know finance who does the
bookkeeping maybe somebody helps you
with marketing maybe that's you somebody
helps you with sales etc right
and so what you can do is you can look
at a department and say what level am i
involved here
right and eventually the goal is that
you can move
right move above right me equals you
know ceo
and so you have a team of leaders who
are building the machine that builds the
machine for you
so that the actual whole thing works
without your
um without you being there besides
providing the vision and strategic
insight for making decisions
right and so for me i define this within
a business where
i'm no longer on the slack channel so in
our portfolio companies
if i am no longer on the slack for that
company meaning no one can reach me
besides the one person who's in charge
of that company
that is what i believe is a truly uh
delegated business that acts as a
portfolio where you are actually an
owner right i can't say the amount of
times i
like i talk to entrepreneurs and they're
like oh yeah i could totally take this
new project on like
my business is totally systematized and
and i'm like
dude like no it's not like your phone's
blowing up twice since we've been on
like since we've been sitting here
talking like like yeah i mean just
because you don't have to respond to
something
in the moment doesn't mean that you
don't have to eventually respond to it
or make a decision or etc
right like those are things that are
still levels of involvement that require
your existence and presence
and so for me it's if i'm not in the
slack channel i have
one meeting a week with the with the
owner of the owner the um
with one of our portfolio companies the
manager operator etc
of a portfolio company and between
that time and the next time the company
can continue to grow without my
direct involvement that is what i would
say is checking all the boxes for me
and if something's not checking all the
boxes you can check all the boxes at a
business level
but you can also just look at this as a
department level and the reason i think
this is so important
is that it can give you a grade that you
can look at to improve so
you might have you know marketing and
you might have sales
and then you might have you know product
and then you might have you know uh
shared services which would be like i.t
legal hr all that kind of stuff right
and you can look at yourself and think
okay do i have
in sales for example do i have people
who can like
am i the one doing the sales okay well
maybe i'm not doing the sales well i'm
the one who's teaching people how to
sell okay
well have i built a machine that teaches
people how to sell so that i don't have
to do the teaching
of selling so i can actually just bring
people in on a consistent basis and get
them up to speed
right that's where you start looking at
like hiring one two three sales people a
month right and they
you put them through the machine that
builds sales people right and so
you can look at these levels within each
of the departments so maybe maybe that's
what you're that's where your sales is
at right you've got a machine that
builds
the machine awesome but is your
marketing there
right do you have a machine that builds
the machine there or are you still doing
are you still teaching people
right and here's here's one of the the
things that
i think for me it took a long time to
realize is that
it's actually your strengths oftentimes
which
which becomes almost always the
bottleneck in the business because
the things that you don't know you're
far more comfortable giving away to
people so that they can build these
things
right because they have better expertise
because they know how to do teach et
cetera and that's where
you as a ceo as an entrepreneur is you
actually have to walk them through these
things so it's like okay great
so uh you know you know how to do some
whatever it is the the delivery of your
of your product you tell someone to do
that
it's like great now i need you to teach
someone else how to do that so we can
build a team of people who are doing
that so we can scale
right and then finally at a certain
point it's like man i'm spending all my
time teaching it's like okay well we
need to build the machine
that does the teaching for you and so i
think if you can think through this
framework for each of the departments
that you have in your company you'll
figure out where your bottlenecks are
and it'll at least give you a grade and
so every quarter you can look at your
your your business on a on a little
little sheet like this and think okay
do people know what to do do we have the
base skill okay do we have the sequence
the how to do it right teaching people
step by step how to do this process
right and hold them accountable
and then finally can i find somebody who
can help systematize and build the
machine that builds the machine that
recreates the skill over and over and
over again and other people
right and so that's kind of the process
and what's interesting if you listen to
uh reid hoffman
founder of linkedin he talks about the
difficulty
for most employees most people
to jump these levels it's very difficult
for most people
which is why especially like rapid rapid
growth companies
they'll often have to you know change
out i'll say leadership with quotes here
just anyone who's in charge because
in the beginning there's probably more
managers and over time there need to be
leaders and a lot of times the managers
despite their tenure aren't actually
leaders right
and so when i'm looking at talent within
our own business i'm thinking okay
who's a good individual contributor and
sometimes sometimes amazing leaders are
terrible individual contributors and
sometimes
a lot often times good individual
contributors are terrible leaders
right and so it takes a very unique
person which is why being an operator so
hard is that you have to really master
all of these levels so that you can
recognize it and teach it in other
people
because ultimately what we're doing is
we have to walk the path that every
person
who's behind us must walk which is why
entrepreneurship is such a
such a growth-oriented you know
occupation like you have to grow
yourself
in order to attract people who have who
are who are at a certain level
right like imagine if you're if you if
you were to start working for somebody
and you feel like you know way more than
them and that they're
just have no idea what they're doing
right then it's unlikely that you're
going to be very influenced by that
person
that person's not going to inspire you
to do anything on the flip side if you
if you were to start working for
somebody and you you aspire to be like
them you like
their character traits you love the way
they operate in their personal life and
how they do business etc
then that is somebody that you were
being led by right and so for us as
entrepreneurs like a lot of times we
have to think like how can i improve my
character what are the traits of mine
that are deficient so that i can
hopefully inspire people
that i can bring people in at this
higher level and then actually be able
to execute because i can't tell you the
amount of times
i can't even like most entrepreneurs
i've talked to i'd say 95 percent of
them oh my team's amazing i love my team
they're awesome
and at the same time they have all these
horror stories about teammates and i
can't say like
amount of times that i've talked to
somebody they said their team was
awesome and i talked to him nine months
later like oh no that team wasn't
awesome this team's awesome right i'm
like
dude the perspective in which you you
make judgments is flawed and i don't
believe anything you say because
every time you've said this it has been
wrong so why would i believe differently
now
and so these are the levels that i think
of for myself my employees
departments and then ultimately the
business this is just a different way of
thinking through it
hopefully is valuable for you if you
have these frameworks you can look at
your own businesses apply things faster
and break through the bottlenecks that
you have so you can get to where you
want to go if you like this
you know subscribe check out one of my
uh my next videos that are coming up
and um hope you uh keeping awesome and
accomplish all your roles